So as many of you know, we have a shortage
of what is called PPE right now, personal
protective equipment.
This includes things like masks and gloves,
face shields, goggles, other equipment that
health care professionals need to safely treat
people with Corona virus without themselves
being at risk of the disease and to try to
minimize the possibility of spreading it to
other people.
For weeks now, Donald Trump has been very
transparently blaming the previous administration.
That's code for Barack Obama for the shortage.
It's been panic at the state level for hospitals
trying to get more people.
Right now, even most of the Corona virus tests
require the administrator to wear PPE.
Hopefully that will change soon.
We're seeing some new rapid self swab tests
come to market, as Trump says, including one
from Abbott, which will start to be available
maybe as early as this week if they're telling
the truth.
But we're really short on PPE because it's
required for tests and for many other reasons.
Friends of mine who are I have two friends
who are E.R. doctors here in Boston work for
different hospital administrators and both
were told they will have one mask to use all
day.
Normally you would be normal, you'd have a
face shield and you change the mask between
patients and put the face shield over it.
They will have one mask for the entire day.
Well, it has now been revealed that Donald
Trump sent a ton of PPE to China, nearly 18
tons of supplies in February, but is now blaming
the previous administration for the shortage.
Check it out.
Here's from talking about the old system inherited
from Barack Obama.
I.
This administration inherited an obsolete,
broken old system that wasn't meant for this.
We discarded that system.
And we now have a new system that can do millions
of people as you need them.
But we had to get rid of a broken old system
that didn't work.
It worked only in a very limited basis.
And we're very proud of what we've done.
It's incredible what we've done.
And this system will now serve for the future
for future problems.
Hopefully you don't have a problem like this,
but something will come up.
We have now a great system and it's almost
fully in gear, but it's able to test millions
of people.
But we inherited a broken old and frankly,
a terrible system.
We fixed it and we've done a great job and
we haven't been given the credit that we deserve
that, I can tell you.
Well, it turns out that a lot of what we are
now experiencing is Trump's own doing.
So aside from, you know, we're in year four
of Trump's presidency, Obama gave Trump the
pandemic response playbook.
The State Department admitted back on February
7th that they facilitated the transportation
of 18 tons of medical supplies to Chinese
people, including masks, gowns, gauze, respirators
and other vital materials.
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo tweeted a video
of a plane being unloaded that was filled
with our stuff back on February 7th.
We gave them the stuff.
We sent them the masks, gowns and all of the
stuff we are now short on, which Trump is
making states compete over.
So it's actually an even more deranged situation
than we believed, which was already, by the
way, very, very deranged.
Trump didn't take the threat seriously here,
called it the Chinese virus blames China.
Now, we have no masks.
We're short on all of the stuff that Trump
is failing to secure for our state governors.
And now we find out he sent a whole bunch
of it to China.
These last six or now closer to eight weeks
have been the biggest failure of the Trump
presidency.
And we may end up I hope not.
We may end up with a death toll that is not
just 10 times higher, but maybe 50 times higher
than it needed to be because of failure after
embarrassing failure by Donald Trump.
Now, let me say something else, because I
know we're going to have a bunch of people
jump in and attack me over this.
I want to be really clear.
This is not me doing some hyper nationalist
argument about Trump should only worry about
Americans and not Chinese people.
That's not the issue here.
The issues here are multiple.
First, the fact that Trump has and continues
to blame the previous administration for things
that were his own decisions that caused the
problems.
That's tragic.
It's disgusting.
And it I fear that it is working actually
with a lot of his followers saying this was
actually Obama's fault.
Number two, the fact that Trump was sending
this stuff to China on February 7th, but only
in early March did he start taking seriously
the procuring of masks and PPE for our hospitals
tells us that for a full month, from early
February to early March, Trump knew we were
low in the stockpile because he sent a bunch
of the stockpile to China.
But he didn't do a damn thing about starting
to replace it for our hospitals until March.
So, again, the criticism is not how dare we
help China.
That's not the critique.
The critique is clearly this is not Obama's
fault.
But more importantly, Trump had a signal on
February 7th or earlier at minimum that we
need to replenish our.
Own supply of masks and other PPE.
And he didn't do it.
And now it's become a scramble that continues
to be a scramble as we are now days from entering
April.
It's incompetence at every turn.
It's not about we should never help China.
It's about don't blame Obama for your mistake.
And also don't act like nobody could have
foreseen this when you knew you depleted your
own stockpile on February 7th.
And then we've got press conferences still
happening, unlike March 25th, where he's saying
we're trying to get masks.
We're trying to get this stuff disgusting.